hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge der
sie zusammen mit es geht sagt hey tag
leid ich wollte euch nur wasserratten
der tsv nicht die tagesschau als
erwartet nicht dass ihr euch was
beibringen
freunde wir wollten uns mal kurz
festhalten wir unterrichten euch hier
nicht übers ziel zu bringen euch gerade
sache beim ich doch in vier folgen haben
wir erst einmal den sieg wirklich gesagt
hat man wenn ihr nicht erwartet können
wir euch auch nicht enttäuscht
also das ist das motto des shop damit
zeigen dass das jetzt machen und damit
fangen wir jetzt an meine lieben freunde
der heutige zieht der nähe
wir haben den mut gezeigt juni - 11 22
34 leuders für komischer sieht alter und
wenn man diesen stein gibt man relativ
genau hier
ich kann hier noch mal zeigen wenn ich
mich einfach gerade tötete dann ist an
on command wenn wir jetzt auf jeden fall
auf reese porten drücke dann wenn ich
hier bei der coba na ja das habe ich
gemacht
ich bin noch nie verstärke ich ja nicht
so stark ist dass sie cool aus aber okay
ich bin jetzt ein baum wie ich mich ja
ich hatte ich war ja es war ganz wie
behindert sind wir so behindert aus weil
ich gerade aus dem bett komme hier in
meinem tollen schlaf shirt gepennt ab
und sollte vielleicht mal den zeigen die
es relativ normaler sie zum klassischer
ja ich kenne ja wir wollen auf jeden
fall hier an diesen koordinaten und wir
haben schon in chat einige koordinaten
rein geschrieben und zwar
denn teleportieren dass ich nach kommt
also erstmal was wir eigentlich meinten
war diese kleine chance in will ja die
ist einfach so eine kleine sandinsel
wurde es nichts besonderes passiert
nicht wenn man von hier nämlich genau
schaut sieht man da hinten einen wasser
tempel müssen wir gar nicht eingehen
oder wenn man ganz genau hinschaut sieht
man auch dort links feindliche tanzdrama
alter ja das ist halt mich das krasse
und zwar dass sowas auftritt ist sauer
selten der fall man hat das eigentlich
immer in diesem riesigen stronghold mit
drin dieses ende pendent aber hier ist
also das ganze wirklich einfach
freigelegtes also das ist wurde wird
zwar immer alles zusammen generiert
allerdings hat das wasser eine höhere
priorität in minecraft irgendwie und
deswegen wird es dadurch ersetzt und
deswegen hat man quasi an diesen
koordinaten an diesen koordinaten 177 41
- 970 jedes geile and portal der ich
sogar schön einladen drin ich finds halt
einfach krass dass du quasi auf dieser
schalte insel bis und schirmer vor du
weißt es gar nicht gut runter und dies
auf einmal dieses portal ich glaube ich
hatte das nahezu noch nie in minecraft
gesehen das ist einfach so quasi
komplett im wasser liegt und du nicht
erst helfer fisch kommt auch an luft
gratwanderung aber wellen wissen
silberfisch ist daum kann er nicht
schwimmen
also ihr könnt ruhig blöcke an der seite
abbauen soll kommt wasser halt rein aber
es halt nicht so schlimm
jedenfalls ist halt an diese koordinaten
diese insel da hinten haben wir einen
tempel wir haben hier überall so ein
paar kleinere inselchen also die
wirklich quasi einfach so herum chillen
so ein bisschen ja wenn man da halt
kostet ein bisschen weiter geradeaus
sieg ist da halt einfach diese center
portal mitten im wasser
ich fühle mich wie so ein keine ahnung
was mit der kapuze auf heute morgen
kingsley rupert huber ich glaub an dich
ich wollte ich ihnen denn behindern
nein
umgehört
sowas geht es tut mir leid dass ich euch
hier gerade beim videoschauen störe aber
es gibt zwei sachen die ich noch kurz
machen muss das erst ist der
adventskalender das hatte ich vergessen
ja deswegen mache ich jetzt da wir den
vierten zwölfter haben öffentlich mal
eben hier das vierte türchen und hinter
dem türchen haben wir ich weiß immer nie
was das darstellen soll
so schaut man wir haben hier so ein
adventskranz bekommen und den können wir
hier nämlich auf so einen kleinen
modernen hocker stellen und dazu haben
wir noch ein kleines prospekten was wir
damit anfangen wollen weiß ich nicht ich
stelle das paar in die landschaft hier
im rhein kommen wir jetzt auch schon zur
zweiten sache nicht ganz kurz ansprechen
wollte uns war es gibt viele leute die
von meinem shop bestellen wollten luca -
shop.de
da haben wir allerdings am ersten tag
nach zwei stunden sagen müssen ja es ist
nahezu alles ausverkauft daher mails
allerdings eine lösung gefunden und zwar
kommen die nächsten sachen erst am 14 12
das ist in zehn tagen allerdings kann
man schon wieder bestellen um diese
sachen an zu erhalten das heißt wenn ihr
unbedingt doch was haben möchte ich kann
euch nicht versprechen ob wie viel doch
das ob überhaupt noch was da es aber
dann solltet ihr auf luca - shop.de
gehen und versuchen noch was zu kriegen
bei den ersten 700 bestellungen wird ein
autogramm dabei sein wenn ihr kein
autogramm dabei bekommen dann tut es mir
leid ich werde solche aktion bestimmt
noch öfters machen dass ich einfach
sticker signieren die dazu packe ich
will gar nicht mehr werbung machen weil
ihr schon alles leer gekauft habt und
für unsere einfach nur schwer noch mehr
jetzt nachschub zu holen aber wenn ihr
unbedingt was wollt kann ich euch nur
empfehlen jetzt auf den shop zu gehen
und jetzt machen wir weiter mit dem
video
6 luka schafft es auch im game und 1
nicht den dreck zu freuen uns euch meine
tolle story aus meinem leben erzählen
wir wollten letztes zusammen trainieren
gehen ins fitnessstudio um was für eine
stunde später saßen beim döner laden
doch er brachte sich hier kann alles
machen noch keine lust mehr man einfach
überhaupt
das halte ich für ein gerücht er leidet
er leidet der leiter der leiter der
leiter der leiter der kommission gibt im
gebiet der stadt waren noch natur
partner mark spitz damit verabschieden
wir uns heute von der 20 uhr tagesschau
da gibt's schon mal vor wie wenn in der
tagesschau ich sitze gerade in unterhose
t shirt allerdings im schlabberpulli ich
bin auch realist gestand wenn ihr
nämlich denkt dass veganer sind als die
tagesschau dann schreibt dem das einfach
mal
ich